and if you get really lucky when you buy
some colostrum you can see like just a
[ __ ] vein or something in there whip
that up using all of the data I have
absorbed from text messages and emails
between you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with I was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages I have selected in the
voice of Stone Cold Steve Austin this is
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary begin it's been
a while [ __ ] love it dude [ __ ]
love it dude you know what dude I
[ __ ] love it
[ __ ] love it dude you know what dude
I [ __ ] love it I [ __ ] love it dude
I [ __ ] love it dude I [ __ ] love it
dude I [ __ ] love it [ __ ] love it
dude
uh this is Stone Cold Steve Austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary it's not
really my diary it's dudesy [ __ ] out
some weird stuff but it's always a fun
thing to read
all right [ __ ] let's get [ __ ] right
into it
May 2nd 1991 yeah dear diary I can't
believe it hell nobody can
all right oh man oh man this is [ __ ]
May 2nd 1991 dear diary I can't believe
it hell nobody can
combo dopplers back in school
now comes a tough kid we all knew that
he used to let firecrackers explode in
his hand and snap mouse traps on his
penis while we were young but breaking
broke through your legs in the tree tank
at the annual Ladner holiday crawl well
that's on a whole nother [ __ ] level
we thought he was gonna miss the rest of
the year and there's no shame in that no
shame at all hell there's only a few
months left to school but he's probably
gonna have to repeat this grade anyway
so I asked him why he came back and get
this
scream Gotham of course this is
principal screen one of the many
characters said School morale was low
made him a [ __ ] deal Tom com comes
back boosts morale screen takes a
Victory lap in exchange screen is gonna
let combo plan the Last Dance of the
season
[ __ ] combo Doppler
combo Doppler May 3rd 1991. dear diary I
just got back from I just got back from
combo's House
he hand selected a cabinet of advisors
who were leaders in their field as the
best football player not only at our
school but in Ladner as a whole
uh of course represented the athletes
Jupiter value represents the musicians
Dante little leg represents the artists
Tabitha Mordred represents the theater
kids and of course Jessamine tenders
represents the academics
first meeting we just spitballed jibber
wanted
first meeting
first meeting we just spitballed jibber
wanted a saxophone band a megaphone hand
a telephone and a banana stand
Dante wanted an original Rembrandt a
visual Remnant a divisional penant and
an individual tenant
Tabitha wanted Harry Tabitha wanted
Harry Potter's daughter slaughtered in
very scary mobster Lobster Waters we
applauded her
Jessamine wanted to meditate educate
delegate and celebrate she called it The
Med Ed Del cell for short kind of a
trump that's a Tronics dude yeah uh
dudes he's learning you know yeah when
they passed me the idea stick I said I
only got one idea two words Sadie
Hawkins and as good as everybody else's
ideas were I could see from the looks on
their faces we all knew whose was the
best
all right God I need something that's
pretty good so you you beat everybody
else's ideas with your your idea to have
a Sadie Hawkins dance yeah yeah Sadie
Hawkins dance all right nah
head full of mucus like colostrum oh God
all right
May 17 1991 dear diary the dance is in
three days but crustacean hasn't asked
me yet oh God
and my network of spies most of whom I
trust
tells me she hasn't asked anyone else
either of course a Sadie Hawkins is when
the group yes a network of spies we
can't go past you that's interesting
when screen signal when screen signed
off on my Sadie Hawkins idea I thought
the pressure was off I thought I didn't
have to worry about asking Rachel
crustacean to the dance because she'd
have to worry about asking me so I'm now
faced with the hellest decision of
possibly breaking the [ __ ]
Sadie Hawkins protocol I installed
myself to ask Rachel crustacean to the
dance or doing nothing and running the
risk of someone else doing it before me
I really wish I could time travel oh the
things I'd see
[Laughter]
May 18 1991 dear diary I'm about to do
it go to Rachel's house and ask her to
the dance I planned it out not leaving
anything to chance here we go wearing
the right cologne wearing the right suit
wearing the right shoes wearing the
right [ __ ] hat wearing the right
[ __ ] pants wearing the right
glasses wearing the where in the wearing
the right toe ring oh
very 90s we're in the right shorts
wearing the right t-shirt we're in the
right tie wearing the right necklace
I never had a necklace quite like this
one actually picked it up at the Occult
Store in Richmond
is there Nicole sir where's Richmond
Richmond is the next town uh over across
the across the water or through the
tunnel as we like to say are they having
a cult store well they have a lot of
stores we actually used to go there
because we didn't have a mall and they
have a couple of malls so I guess if
you're looking for
um you know an Occult Store or a
necklace why not it's an amulet and
pretty and a pretty ancient wanted that
the guy at the store told me it can
grant wishes if you get it given an
offering of human blood I'm gonna wear
it kind of hanging over my turtleneck
just gives a whole look a pop hope and
crustacean likes it
all right well uh that's it yeah that's
it so I'm sure what happens at the
[ __ ] dance with who's this guy combo
diddler back in combo Doppler combo
Doppler not combo diddler he's a he's a
wrestler that's his brother oh [ __ ] dude
you're about to ask crustacean okay so
so wonderful the next time that we the
next time that we uh hear from this
hopefully combo Doppler and uh
using the day die have absorbed from
this segment I have recreated the Diary
of Rachel crustacean Alex borisstein
will now read a passage from Rachel
crustacean's diary what the [ __ ]
oh boy oh my [ __ ] god May 18th
1991. dear diary Will Sasso asked me to
the dance well he didn't exactly ask me
to the dance
he asked me if I asked anybody
I said no but Tandy
Baggins asked me then he asked me what I
said to Tandy and I told him I told
Tandy say d
Hopkins dances have invites from ladies
so I had to say sorry to Tandy the
invite is supposed to come from me
but the truth is not just about say d
it's that I don't want to go with Tandy
I truthfully want to go with Willie so I
asked him if he would go with me
then he stood there staring at me
blankly
he was so nervous that he needed to use
my bathroom but the toilet in the living
room is broken so he used the bathroom
in my mom and dad's bedroom when he came
out he said yes
so I'm officially going to the Last
Dance of the season with Will Sasso
after he left my mom went into her
bathroom to brush her teeth and came out
like she had seen a murder oh my God
I guess will really clogged it up bad
made a mess
my mom had to use a cake knife to get it
all down I know it sounds gross but in a
weird way
I found it cute that will put on his
best suit and a weird necklace and got
that nervous about asking me and I
didn't want my mom to not like him so I
told her I did it
oh my God ah dude Rachel crustacean I
don't even know what to do right now my
head is spinning Alex Borstein just read
Rachel cross station and Rachel
crustacean just [ __ ] blamed herself yeah
to make her mom like you
listen [ __ ] is deep on duty this is
unreal once we finish I'm gonna be
texting my dear pal Al my sister Alex
Morrison wow dude uh how did the um
whatever the lit the lips I'm [ __ ]
thank you moving on
review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell the friends
[Music]
and then